well welcome to a new video and the
first one so alrighty against strong
Grandmaster you recopa get a double
fianchetto maybe u transpose to
symmetrical English now if it takes on
d4 at least yeah this is also possible
by the way if adjusted the pieces a bit
to make them really like pieces a bit
darker I hope it sir it's okay
okay let's see what is playing now this
is an interesting position yeah now
I hope I forgot to Syria I have to admit
yeah I think I take now yeah okay let's
see he can take on the phone now with
various pieces yeah now it's possible to
take on b7 but don't think this is a
good position I have another idea here
take on d4 first now black most likely
will capture with the bishop yeah now I
take an f5 if he captures the rook now
on a one I would have at night h6 now i
have to of course move the rock away
yeah no white is a pawn down but it's an
interesting position let's see if I can
get some compensation here for the pawn
yeah I go with check first
now now i can play submission page three
in order to provoke e6
yeah no idea this is enough for paul
weitz idea of course to get the clean d
6 on porn back here and maybe get some
initiative because of black somewhat
weakened King but it's not not huge
problem for black of course okay not
sure where I should go now maybe go to
f4
you cannot play we should be fine
because I could take em
yeah one thing that needs to be
mentioned is that we've got opposite
colored bishops which is sort of a small
insurance policy for why that if it's
not enough compensation then often the
end game if we get one and I would still
be rather dry k ideas to get more pieces
on on the deep pawn and maybe play f4 at
some point to really get this pawn back
I don't want to play well I don't want
to play Queenie too because of f4 then
you would be able to get rid of from one
of his pawns mm-hmm whatever play this
now thread of F form to get back the
porn and fork both pieces yeah he
retreats now yeah maybe a for now and
then Queen d2
and maybe it's got t5 now not sure ok
let's drop this one back
yeah yeah this should be enough for a
pawn because black young has no chance
to to really improve the position deep
onus always backwards I try now to to
get a little bit of play on the
queenside maybe this is not a good idea
i'm not sure i could have just kept the
position as it was and now is
threatening d5 trusting
maybe get rid of the Queen now and then
try to put pressure on b7 you know maybe
this was really unnecessary i played
this I'm not sure it still looks like
some play but
I need to get the king over I can always
get this one back i think with you was a
clumsy move ya know black is very much
better of course
maybe this one Bishop do before I can
maybe capture here
maybe it's still not entirely clear take
here you can take on c4 of course okay
time warning
yeah maybe it's best to keep this pawn
to give up the exchange now
we get some counter play with the idea
of getting the rook to e8 this is still
a strong porn okay I guess now he will
return the exchange okay it looks some
unpleasant say the least wow I supports
going through well that was this was
really stupid okay we first gave oh my
ok let's resign this one and go for a
new new game I I think this is this was
a stupid yeah of course it was it was
was pretty simply I could I could just
stay here and nothing would happen in
this game but hmm not sure about about
this this kind of position because I
could play something else here I guess
the simplest due to just to just stay
here because black cannot do anything
simply he is no no weights of altering
the pawn structure and to some pretty
easy draw I think I'm i have no active
play myself but i can just keep the
position as is